This image combining line art and
a photo was saved as a JPEG and
it looks fine on a phone
at small display sizes.
But on a desktop monitor,
resizing the browser window,
the JPEG format begins
to show its weaknesses.
With JPEG, edges can lead to artifacts.
For this example, SVG for
the logo would have scaled better.
Here's the same with SVG for
the logo over a JPEG of the photograph.
The photo and
the logo both look good small or large.
You can see those crisp edges there.
Both look great.
File sizes are down too.
Here's the version with the logo over
the image as a, one single JPEG.
And here we have the version
with the SVG over the JPEG.
And you can see that even though
we need an extra file request,
we're actually only using
about half as many bytes.
Take a look at these three logos.
They look identical, right?
But if you check with the dev tools,
you'll see that we've used three
different file formats and there's
a massive difference in file sizes.
The chrome.svg there is, well,
it's about a 25th the size of the PNG.
There are some good general rules for
improving cross-platform
image performance.
Use JPEG for photographic images, and
browsers such as Chrome also support
other formats, such as WebP, which can
deliver better compression and features.
WebP supports alpha transparency
animation along with lossy and
lossless compression.
Now, if you can, use SVG for
vector images, and
we'll show you how to do that later.
And for vector art and
solid color graphics, such as logo and
line art,
if you're unable to use SVG, use PNG.
And do use PNG rather than GIF.
More colors, better compression and
no licensing issues.
For more information
about image formats,
take a look at the links
below the video.